مدنيا ايضا اعلنت الاداره العسكريه في
خرسون عن مقتل شخص واصابه اربعه في قصف
روسي استهدف احياء في المدينه واحصت
الاداره العسكريه في خرسون اكثر من 300
قذيفه اطلقت على الضفه اليمنى لنهر الخاضع
لسيطره الاوكرانيه وقالت الاداره العسكريه
في ميكولايف في بيان قصفا بالمدفعيه
الثقيله استهدف منطقه
جنوبيه المقاطعه ماده الى اضرار ماديه في
مباني سكنيه وتضرر مؤسسه تجميع المياه
والتي تعرضت لاستهداف مباشر
قالت الخارجات الروسيه ان الهجوم على تم
باسلحه الناتو وانه جريمه لن تمر دون عقاب
واضافت ان الغرب يطالب كياف بمواصله
العمليات الهجوميه واحتلال اراضي روسيه
جديده لكن هذه الخطط محكوم عليها بالفشل
وكدت الخارجيه الروسيه استمرار ما سمتها
العمليه الخاصه لروسيا الى ان تكتمل مهام
نزع السلاح في اوكرانيا وتنتهي التهديدات
الامنيه